phone hacking private investigators
intercepted voicemails the Duke of
Sussex has taken the stand in his most
public battle against the Press yet
blaming the newspapers for inciting
hatred and harassment in his private
life no cameras no recordings or allowed
in court but will bring you the
highlights of the evidence played by an
actor this is Prince Harry in court a
Sky News special
the Duke of Sussex is fighting Fleet
streets to Prince Harry's action against
the Daily Mirror is underway are the
events surrounding his mother's death
presents the media bringing damages
claims against the mirror group he heard
how alleged hacking engulfed his whole
life
Harry's court papers make huge
allegations this is Prince Harry versus
the papers round three
good evening I'm Jonathan Samuels and
today Prince Harry appeared in court to
give evidence becoming the first senior
Royal to take to the witness box since
the 1890s the prince was subject to
tough cross-examination at times heated
but mostly the Duke appeared calm and
serious saying that thousands of
incredibly invasive articles affected
his life and that are the people around
him
the Royal arrived at the Royal courts of
Justice today for the most anticipated
court case in recent times surrounded by
media from around the world
throughout this hour-long program will
bring you the best bits of the testimony
and the cross-examination played by an
actor it is the closest account you will
see of what happened in court
we're joined tonight by Persephone
Bridgeman Baker media lawyer and partner
at Carter Rock and Paul con you former
editor of the Sunday Mirror and former
deputy editor of the Daily Mirror and a
media commentator great to see you both
this evening we shall chat in a moment
so it has been hasn't it a truly
historic day a senior member of the
royal family walked into court to give
testimony for the first time in more
than 130 years let's get straight into
what we heard when the Duke of Sussex
took the stand and the oath I swear by
almighty God that the evidence that I
shall give shall be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth
well that is our actor who will be
voicing moments of the prince's evidence
in court throughout tonight's program
let's bring in our guests
um and uh it is great to get your
thoughts and your analysis on what
happened uh on what has been a
fascinating day and Paul what a moment
did you ever think uh in your lifetime
you would see a member of the royal
family walk into the high court and
stand and give the oath in a word no
um it's quite extraordinary it's not
just High drama it's sort of like a
royal soap opera and I mean it it really
is quite extraordinary uh you're in
courts today I'd love to know what the
atmosphere was like and also tell me
about that opening statement by the
lawyer who was cross-examining Harry
because he began rather unexpectedly
with an apology yeah so atmosphere
outside Court very busy lots of press
busy inside quotes as about a full court
full over spill room of journalists and
and that opening statement by Harry the
first question he's asked on that oath
which he's just given is um is this case
really about these 33 articles and the
mirror group or is it just about the
Press intrusion which you say you've
suffered for your whole entire life and
and his the mirror group Barrister
apologizes at that stage and says you
know and for that on behalf of the press
you know I'm very sorry for everything
that you've suffered and if at any point
during this process you want to just
take a moment because of it then then
feel free to so it was a sort of
dramatic start to um to what the rest of
the day happened wasn't that the only
option for the for the mirror group
lawyers in as far as the company has
paid out a hundred million pounds in in
compensation to phone hacking and other
intrusive
methodology that that getting that in
first was it was it was a good was a
good tactic oh well you sound quite like
Harry now
saying well because they've done it once
they must have done it again and that
was a thing we kept on seeing coming
through today yeah okay well we'll chat
more uh in a moment but I just want to
bring in our Royal correspondents uh
Laura bundock Laura has been at court
all day evening Laura Harry has wanted
this moment for years hasn't he how
would you sum up today's at remarkable
events
extraordinary historic day we have had a
senior Royal the son of the king
testifying at the high court this
doesn't happen this isn't what members
of the Royal Family do it hasn't
happened in living memory now Harry's
legal team are very happy they say with
how it all went today they would say
that of course but I think it does show
there were real worries about how he was
going to cope under the pressure of
quick fire cross-examination now if the
mirror group Barrister had hoped to
Goose him today it didn't work Harry
seemed calm he seemed controlled
throughout but it certainly wasn't an
easy ride for him he was asked direct
difficult questions about all these
articles asked to prove how it was that
these articles came about because of
illegal activities like phone hacking
and blagging it was really intense in
court but let's not forget this is
exactly what Harry wanted he wanted it
all said he wanted it all heard in open
court today because he has this greater
purpose this bigger Mission he wants to
expose what went on and to hold those
responsible to account this is only the
beginning his witness statement I
thought read like a Manifesto to all of
this he says in it he had a front row
seat when it came to hacking he wants to
expose it and he believes we will all be
better off as a result of this now we
are one day in one day done no big
mistakes no big gaffs his team think it
went well but there is still tomorrow
and still more cross-examination to come
indeed Laura thank you very much well as
we have been hearing Prince Harry was
cross-examined for much of the day today
and throughout this hour-long special we
will keep bringing you the drama from
the high court delivered by our actor
once the formalities were completed the
cross-examination of Prince Harry began
representing mirror group newspapers
Andrew Green Casey pressed the Duke of
Sussex on his memory of some of the
oldest articles included in his case the
Duke was asked how an article he didn't
read or have any recollection of could
have caused him distress and again with
the help of our actor here's how Harry
responded compared to now and 1996 I was
a child I was at school
these articles were incredibly invasive
and each time one of these articles were
written it had an effect on my life the
people around me my mother in this case
her reaction to me as her son
well Mr Green continued to drill down on
the Duke's memory of articles that in
some cases are now more than two decades
old Prince Harry described the impact
the newspaper articles had had on his
life when I say the contents I believe
that again as a child every single one
of these articles played an important
role a destructive role in my growing up
to give any confirmation that I can
specifically remember reading the
Articles at the time I believe would be
speculation
yes as you said more than thousands
maybe millions of Articles have been
written about me since age 12.
yes because again because it's 20 years
ago I simply cannot speculate how it was
and whether I saw these articles at the
time I certainly saw lots of Articles at
the time
the ones I was made aware of because of
the behavior and reaction of people in
my inner circle
unfortunately stories that you've only
that I've only shared with one or two
people within my inner circle ends up
front page of newspaper or any page
your circle of friends starts to shrink
and
diminish rather rapidly
mmm Persephone it's been a continuing
line of attack hasn't it all day today
um if Harry hadn't read the articles at
the time how can he now be distressed by
them or what what's the thinking here
well that was the forensic analysis
which the mirrors Barrister was taking
Harry through today on an article by
article basis and it sounds rather more
sensationalist when you read it in the
Press today than it was in court because
it was a really forensic line of
questioning about whether or not there
were the the possibility of any other
sources for these articles had the
information in the Articles being
published elsewhere already and what he
was saying essentially was it was it
this article
for which there was an awful information
gathering and was it this article which
caused you the distress or was it the
general press intrusion which was
happening at the time yeah what did you
make at Apple I agree I agree
um interestingly I've been talking to a
couple of well-connected contracts one
and one in the royal family or near the
coach the royal family and one Close to
the Mirror group in the mirror group's
case this morning it's like a cricket
match that was the analogy used this
morning they weren't very happy they
expected
Andrew Green who's known as the Beast
for his uh for Ramsey across examination
skills they thought he they thought
Prince Harry had remarkably stood up as
better than they expected but as the day
went on it's a bit like a quick match
after lunch in fact uh Andrew Green was
bowling some pretty hostile bouncers
that prince Andrew was finding it more
difficult to actually fend off and I
would anticipate tomorrow morning the
bowling will become even fiercer but a
royal contact said that what was really
going to shock and surprise King Charles
who is funnily enough of course at his
Cottage in transport Transylvania the
land of Vlad the Impaler was the
reference to uh to politics hitting rock
bottom which was you know throwing that
in was I think was a surprise and as
someone said it was a bit like Prince
Harry is trying to impale both the royal
family and the media at the same time I
think the other thing that that really
came across certainly in the in the
first few hours is
um how how young Harry was when a lot of
these articles came out you know he was
11 12 years old and of course that's so
impressionable yeah it's a really long
time ago to be remembering and trying to
recall these facts and which articles he
read and what did cause the distress
which you're saying was cool so that's
genuinely a difficult a difficult call
yeah hard to remember that that far back
of course okay uh well we have heard
some of the evidence there and I just
want to take you back a little bit let's
rewind at the moment he was sworn in
today the court released that his
witness statement here it is uh it's
more than 50 pages long it's all written
in the prince's words and here's a
little bit of what Prince Harry said
about the tabloids are in this statement
they then start to edge you towards
playing the role or roles that suit them
best and which sells as many newspapers
as possible especially if you are the
spare to the air you'll then either the
Playboy Prince the failure the Dropout
or in my case the thicker the cheat the
under age Drinker irresponsible drug
taker the list goes on as a teenager and
in my early 20s I ended up feeling as
though I was playing up to a lot of the
headlines and stereotypes that they
wanted to pin on me and in the witness
statement the Duke of Sussex accused the
Tabloid press of having blood-stained
hands something Harry was asked about in
court the lawyer said who has blood on
their hands some of the editors and
journalists who are responsible for
causing a lot of pain upset
in some cases maybe inadvertently deaf
yeah really powerful that Paul wasn't it
really really powerful
um I did find it a little hard when
Prince Harry was trying to suggest that
the media were determined to break up
his relationships with girlfriends uh
that that I did I I just can't see that
the media obviously intrigued fascinated
and you know arguably certainly have
exceeded uh proper conduct at times but
but they weren't setting it setting out
to destroy his relationships they were
there was a huge interest in him among
the media arguably too much among the
public so I found I found that a little
a little desperate to say the media
wanted to destroy his relationship
somehow wreck his life because if you
look if you look back there have been
many positive stories that you know that
you know the hero the hero Soldier
Prince Harry in fact so it swings both
ways it's not it's not all the media a
monstering Harry from pretty much from
birth is the way he put it in one in one
sentence in in his statement they were
you know from from the day I was born
well I mean that's absurd yeah it always
goes back to to whether or not he has a
has a vendetta against the prince it's
not a word that he uses is it but of
course many people are wondering if that
is what this is all about well it very
much goes to the rhetoric of the start
of the witness statement which is where
the mirror groups Barrister got that
question from is this really about these
33 articles or is it actually just about
this fairly awful experience that you've
had at the hands of the press over many
many years and when we say press we
don't just mean mirror group we mean you
know tabloid press as a whole yeah and
of course the the the mirror group have
admitted uh one case wrongdoing haven't
they they have but it's on okay it's on
the instance of a rogue journalist
rather than what Harry's seeking to um
to portray which is that this is a
campaign which has been sort of
authorized by the top and trickled down
across the group
um you've been a newspaper hack Paul uh
you've edited newspapers when we see
these headlines from 20 years ago or so
some of them feel really old-fashioned
they feel like the sort of stories that
even the Tabloid press wouldn't
necessarily cover today is that fair I
think that's true I think I think the
climate has changed Harry would argue
I'm sure that it hasn't changed enough
enough but that's where he's coming from
I think I think things have have a
change for the better and and Harry
seems determined to almost provoke
leperson 2 being revived like which I
don't think any government is going to
do not so not that the present
government I don't think Kayer storm if
he wins the next election would make
that a priority at all but that's the
way Harry sees it but we've also got to
be careful here that uh that this case
doesn't damage the fact we do need a
free press in this country and and
without doubt there's been a lot of bad
behavior and illegality but the
importance of a free press is still
precious yeah we'll have to talk a bit
more about that uh later on in the
program I want to discuss now Prince
Harry's relationship with Chelsea Davey
it's already been a big part of this
trial uh hasn't it well a number of the
Articles within the prince's case
against MGM focus on the couple's time
together this article by the mirrors
Roar reporter Jane Kerr and published
around 2004 claimed Harry had been in
introduced to Miss Davis father days
before the businessman was accused of
making a profit from Africa's trophy
hunting trade
well first of all Prince Harry expressed
his concerns about the way the
information was gathered to get that
story
the paragraph that says
Harry will fly back to Britain on
December 19th that not only is that a
security issue I can't begin to imagine
how they would find that information out
without blogging
flight blogging could have been done
through phone hacking either way I'm not
entirely sure how these journalists one
of those being Jane Kerr how they would
ever know what date I'm flying and
having the confidence to put that in a
national newspapers
advertising my travel plans
yeah it goes back to that paranoia
doesn't it that he said that he felt for
much of his life as he was being chased
by the Tabloid press and this is what
people have been in the Press today
calling The Smoking Gun of today this is
really probably the only article on
which there's no real other explanation
as to how that information could have
been found found out and no other
Publishers as I understand it had
published it so it's really the one
article I think that's going to cause
concern for the defendant's team off the
back of today because another line of
attack which has been running throughout
the day is the fact that the information
in many of the articles that he's
brought actually did appear in other
newspapers it appeared on the BBC even
on press Association
um in the hours or even sometimes the
days before the mirror published it's a
it's a mixed bag in fact you know
we were talking earlier in fact it seems
strange some of the some of these
stories they're citing don't seem seem
to be
why are they why are they in there why
didn't they actually reduce it down to
the more blatant it seems to me not just
a lawyer but as a journalist it seems to
me that
he has a stronger case on blogging
perhaps than on than on on phone hacking
and it's very and they also seem to be
relying on trying to tie up
whether successful or not they're trying
to tie up the fact that
many of the journalists whose bylines
are on certain stories were named in the
2003 operation motor man inquiry by the
information commissioner's office and
they're trying to say well if they were
found to be blagging then they must have
been blagging to get the to get these
stories it's it's a woman was almost
guilt by association you know in it's
the tactic yeah I mean we discussed that
a bit yesterday didn't we that this case
is built on inference and and Harry said
a number of times today well the the
this is the same mirror group that are
guilty of hacking it's been found out
that these journalists have done this
previously they've like they've hacked
and so they must be doing it again but
it's that leap he's got to to persuade
the judge that just because of the
circumstantial evidence there's enough
for him to um to persuade the court on
the balance of probabilities that it did
take place because there is a lack of
phone data as we've as we've heard Harry
didn't seem particularly across that
data there were a number of times when
he said all you know my lawyers have the
evidence or they showed me something and
he didn't particularly seem across the
underlying the detail of the underlying
documents today yeah I mean how much of
this is about persuading the judge the
the judge has got it he's got to weigh
everything up and it's a balance isn't
it and it is just on the balance and
probabilities and I don't want to
diminish that but it's a significantly
lower threshold than you would have in a
criminal case for example
um and it's you know it's it's the
balance of probability is 50 50. it was
it more likely than not
um so he you know he may get there on a
number of the Articles yes when you're
looking at the social media feed a lot
of the public don't quite see it in the
way where the law is acting they think
it's it's either guilty it's either
guilty or or innocent not I mean it
could be a nuanced judgment that the
judge could decide that of the 33 5
stand up to in his view is supporting
Harry's case you know 2028 might not you
know but I think Harry would and his
team would see the victory if they even
get secure one because he's fighting
this and the court of public opinion not
just the Law Court well you can see the
headline can't you you know Harry hack
by mirror group if there's even one
article about it there's a he that he
wins on yeah it's a good point um okay
well let's uh let's go back to the
cross-examination because a little bit
later Andrew Green the lawyer for the
mirror pushed the prince on why he
thought the article was distressing and
whether Harry had read it at the time
now I'm going to help with the
interaction here and explain what the
lawyer said in court that's an
assumption I may have done
you don't know replied the Barrister I
don't know so long ago when do you think
you first read this article I can't say
and what is so distressing about it
it's as distressing reading and looking
at it now as the first time I saw it Mr
Green repeats and what is so distressing
about it a level of detail myself
relationship between myself and my
girlfriend my travel plans being
broadcast to a huge audience are you
equally distressed about contents of
articles in the Daily Express mail on
Sunday and the sun yes
yeah Persephone what did you make of
that admission where he said yes other
papers as well were equally distressing
it's difficult for him he's got to show
that these articles that we're
discussing in this case are the ones
that cause the distress which she's
claiming for and he's now bringing in as
he has actually in the witness statement
as well a lot of other Publishers into
the mix this is causation isn't it that
you were talking about that's the
causation Point yes yeah Paul no I no I
agree
um although I'm no cheerleader for Harry
as you as you know but I think I'm not
sure though I would necessarily know now
what how I might have reacted to
situations in my own life 30 years ago
for example so so I think I'm not sure
quite sure you know tackling him and
well if he didn't didn't complain then
or weren't and that distressed then why
are you now you know but I think one
thing that's a personal Viewpoint to the
personal Theory I think in a sense
Harry's perceived a treatment the way
his Megan's been treated has really
propelled this and put it and put it
into warp speed whether whether he would
have gone down this route or so fiercely
down it if it wasn't for that I don't
know yeah I'm interested as well to know
um how much information Harry will have
been given before he gave his evidence
we know that he can't be tutored in his
answers but in terms of what you saw in
court today as he was giving his
evidence um did you feel he was quite
Polished in some of his answers because
some of that cross-examination was
tricky he was very calm and collected
certainly and I think that that line of
questioning which is the forensic
questioning which is going to go on that
went on throughout the whole of today
and will carry on tomorrow is the sort
of questioning which early on in the day
it is much easier to deal with than when
it's gone on for a really long time and
you're suffering from realizing that
maybe your answers that you gave earlier
might be causing your problems now so I
think we'll see you have to see how that
develops tomorrow but we've certainly
got a hint of that towards the end of
today yeah did he get as tougher time as
perhaps you expected I think knowing
what's more important than me I think I
think base people at the mirror I mean
among senior figures there I think they
I thought they were as I said were
surprised by how well he played you know
the the fast bowling in the morning but
as the day went on they felt that he was
uh he wasn't actually uh his Bat was
rather getting a few holes but I but I
think it's going to be interesting
tomorrow morning because I think Andrew
Green will you know will actually be
bowling harder and faster with a few
more bounces but what I found
interesting was the application
by Harry's legal team for an extra three
for three hours after Harry's finishing
evidence to to interrogate you know the
mirrors first journalists to step
forward and as we were saying last night
and predicting last night they kept
coming back to you know to this point
you know Harry kept saying it to the
judge I'm here being cross-examined
where are the authors of these articles
you you know with before you why aren't
why aren't they that's interesting but
who's it down to it's down to Harry to
provide the evidence isn't it well it's
down to Harry to provide the evidence
and actually it came up both ways today
at points um the mirror groups Barrister
said to him well you could have called
these people about the leagues to
discuss where this whether they were the
sources for stories Etc so that cuts
both ways I think
um yeah yeah could they subpoena a
mirror mirror reporters I thought it was
the mirror's job to actually decide who
they were going to put forward it's the
mirror's job to decide who they would
put put up as Witnesses okay we may find
out more in coming days um thank you
both for the moment do stay with us
coming up after the break we're going to
bring you the moment the lawyer
cross-examining Harry accused him of
total speculation in connection to this
article
foreign
[Music]
India's fatality rate is less than two
percent one of the lowest in the world
the concern here is that the Public
Health Care system is inadequate
it is
and now they're going to be arrested we
aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
foreign
[Music]
undated the only way out is to get
people by boat
what is shared that over 200 people
might have died because of these
landslides
[Music]
one day would have been bustling with
people but today it's
asserted
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of of Northeast Delhi where there's been
clashes
water based in Delhi
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to this special program
Harry in court coming up more of what
the Duke of Sussex said and the
cross-examination as spoken by our actor
now Harry believes many of the stories
written about him weren't in the public
interest they include this article it's
about when he broke his thumb he was
playing uh football at school and Harry
was asked by the mirror groups Barrister
Andrew Green if he thought the article's
author it was written by Jane Kerr the
then Royal editor had potentially hacked
the phones of medical staff who'd
treated him I believe it was either
probably herself or she got someone else
to do the dirty work for her again this
story for any journalist would want to
take it further due to pressure from
their editors
well Mr Green followed with whose phone
do you think was hacked for this article
I can't be sure my Lord I don't have the
call data
the Barrister then pressed the Duke
saying that's not an answer and asked
the question again
the doctors I'm not sure I can't be sure
Mr Green
well in a more heated exchange Andrew
Green asked Prince Harry if he thought a
journalist hacked the doctor's phone
number adding and we're not in the
Realms of total speculation
no I don't believe so again I'm not the
one who wrote the article you'd have to
ask the one who wrote the article
um well let's bring in our experts once
again Persephone Bridgeman Baker media
lawyer and partner at Cataract and Paul
Connor former editor of the Sunday
Mirror and former deputy editor of the
Daily Mirror as well and here we are
again Persephone it's interesting isn't
it um you know who who exactly had their
phone hacked so why can't you tell us
who it was and then he says that well
you'll have to ask the people involved
um and also that line about other media
Outlets having printed this story as
well that came up a lot today and that's
a forensic line of questioning by the
mirrors Barrister about well these
allegations had already been published
in a another newspaper when this article
that you're now complaining about was
published and Harry looked a little
flummoxed by those sorts of questions
I'm quite interested about stories from
when Harry was at school because there
was that agreement wasn't there that the
Press would leave the boys alone during
those school years yes yes there was and
it worked pretty well although without
doubt there were there were breaches of
it but it did work it did work fairly
well
somebody else that was interesting about
that article is that it even mentions
within it when William broke his arm a
couple of years earlier and Charles
complained to the Press complaints
commission
um so you know it's got a weird uh
situation where you've got an article
that Harry is complaining about even
mentioning a previous complaint
yes you're absolutely right I mean Harry
made a made a lot of points today about
um the fact that he even he admitted
that a lot of this was just speculation
as well
um he said at points I'm just reading
off from what I scribbled down in court
today and he said at a point I'm just
speculating and it could have been
lifted from a voicemail and admitted
that it would have been incredibly risky
to have hacked his phone or any of the
other Royals phones but but of course
the it was also suggesting uh that it
didn't be his phone that was hacked it
was that of Associates aides advisors to
the royal family or members of the even
of Prince Charles as he was then
it's senior staff
um so that's where the argument came
back which was which was well why aren't
those people here in court
both ways
um today didn't it it did it did it did
it's going to be very hard to I wouldn't
like to be predicting how this one how
this one is going to end actually no
does it I mean does this case crumble if
we're here a lot more examples like this
I think there's a real possibility that
as the mirrors Barrister takes Harry
through each of these articles and he
admits that he can't remember when he
read them if he read them can't recall
how or what distress was caused that
there could have been sources that were
from for example other newspapers repeat
Publications from other stories that had
already been written that the mirrors
Barrister is able to draw that line of
argument back round and say really this
is just a case about General press
intrusion that you're unhappy with isn't
it and not just those 33 articles and
that's quite sort of criminal law line
of cross-examination but I imagine that
that might be where tomorrow goes I'm in
a broken thumb of a Schoolboy playing
football
um even if it's a member of the royal
family isn't that big a story is it well
what about the public interest uh
defense here because that's something
else that Harry has talked a lot about
in his books I mean the broken thumb is
a trivial story it's page 29 lead at
best but the issue is how would it tell
you now I I would be amazed if a random
Doctor Who I mean who would who would
know who was treating gehari at a e
um if and it's always important to say
if if that was illegally obtained it's
more it's more likely to be a blogging
case where somebody rang up and
pretended to be a member of the uh the
Royal householder just checking on Harry
some detail about Harry and in fact and
uh and somebody was naive enough to
actually to actually answer the question
that came up in the evidence evidence
today actually that that's the sort of
material which might have been obtained
by by blagging um and of course you know
this I'm just thinking the witness
statement which is headed in the matter
of the mirror newspapers hacking
litigation but the blogging is certainly
something which on the Articles which
perhaps Harry fared better on today
seemed to be more along the lines of
lagging than hacking yeah very
interesting and just uh briefly explain
what blagging means for people who
perhaps don't know blogging is the
obtaining of information
unlawfully by essentially by deception
let's say say posing as a member of
Prince Harry's staff ringing up or at
the royal family staff or or it's it's
important basically it's impersonation
this is what the operation motor man
inquiry was all about which which
although they haven't mentioned it by
name they keep coming back to this you
know in Harry's statement saying that
you've got to look at at the same
journalists who were condemned by the
information commissioner in 2003 a lot
of their names are on are on the
articles that you know that I am saying
were illegally obtained so so as we're
saying it's not in itself definite proof
but they're trying to imply well once a
blogger almost a blogger that that is
the line they're taking it's quite a
leap I mean there was a point that one
of the questions today was by the
Barrister the mere fact that someone has
an interest in you doesn't necessarily
mean that the information was obtained
by unlawful information gathering and
Harry said it does when it's a group
that have admitted to hacking already
but that is that's quite a jump it is it
is okay uh thank you both for the moment
uh we'll keep bringing you uh the drama
from the high court delivered by our
actor for the rest of this program and
for more analysis set from today's event
in court you can scan the QR code you
can see it on your screen right now and
take a listen to the latest edition of
The Sky News Daily podcaster Leah
belletto and our Royal correspondent
Laura bundock take you through
everything you need to know about the
Duke's appearance in court with a media
lawyer Jonathan code and you can
subscribe to the Daily of course for
free wherever you get your podcast from
now after the break we'll discuss what
the Duke of Sussex had to say about
Piers Morgan and we'll speak to someone
who was a victim of phone hacking don't
go away
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
hello again welcome back to this special
program Harry in court coming up more of
what the Duke of Sussex said under
cross-examination as spoken by our actor
still with me Persephone Bridgeman Baker
and Paul Conneaut will be speaking to
them again in a moment but right now I'm
very pleased to say that joining me in
the studio is Jackie Haynes a director
of hacked off who campaigned for free
and accountable press uh good to see you
thank you very much for joining us um
also a victim of phone hacking although
you don't like the phrase necessarily
victim do you but it'd be interesting to
know what you thought of today's
um uh incredible events really seeing
and hearing Harry in the witness box
something that you've had to do um well
I didn't give evidence in um a civil
action I wasn't in the position to be
able to Harry is probably one of the few
people that can has the financial clout
understanding to be able to achieve that
I wasn't given that opportunity but I
did give evidence at part one of the
leverson inquiry and I think watching
that that Court proceedings today it was
so sad in many respects and so
frustrating because none of this needed
to happen if we'd had part two of the
leverson inquiry all these things would
have come out the questions that are
being put to Harry today should have
been put
um into that we know when the conclusion
of the criminal trials which is when
part two was scheduled to start and all
this would have been aired we could have
dealt with it and Harry wouldn't have
had to put himself through this just
remind us what happened to you well I
was doing two parts really I I was
married to someone who's investigating a
murder of a private investigator who's
business partner was very close with the
news of the world
the murder
was Notorious it was involving police
corruption and
um we as a result of my husband
investigating that murder we thought we
were being targeted by suspects in that
murder you know we were being followed
we had
um interference in things like our mail
people were trying to intrude into bank
accounts moving things in our home that
sort of thing
and then one of the vans that was
following us that this is back in 2002
was stopped and it turned out actually
the occupants following us were employed
by the news of the world which was
completely left field and by this time
we've been put under the witness
protection scheme so all that was
happening back in 2002 and then you fast
forward to 2011 we find also that Glenn
mulcair whose notebooks are now famous
of a a record of all the phone hacking
that took place and blagging also
featured certainly in my case lots of
personal information that must have come
from my police personnel file as well as
information about my mobile phones and
and in fact the news of the world
settled a phone hacking claim yeah and
very distressing especially when you
first hear how your life has been
infiltrated in that way in Harry's case
the mirror of course denies all but one
of the charges that he's bringing
um investigative reporting even if it's
unpalatable sometimes do you still
believe it's important absolutely I do
I'm a great Advocate I mean I think of
all the wonderful journalists we've got
in this country and the stories that
they've un uh uncovered and pursued and
relentlessly and thank God for them but
we have a we have and had a culture of
criminality throughout the Tabloid
journalism this is not about public
interest this is about abuse of power
this is about abusing people's Liberty
and private data in order to you know
raise
um money it's difficult balance though
isn't it because we do need a free press
we do absolutely but that doesn't mean
to say it shouldn't be accountable and
everybody who has huge power is
accountable in this country and now and
our a lot of the journalists senior news
editors and in fact Publishers are not
holding our public uh politicians and
royal family to account they're holding
them to Ransom and that's the wrong
shift of power I suppose the problem is
that that many people will watch this
case and see and hear what Harry has to
say and so this isn't actually about
reform it's about revenge
well I mean I can't answer for Harry
that's purely a matter for him but
clearly he's put everything on the line
um here to actually bring this into the
public domain to actually almost
replicate what should have happened and
still should happen in levison part two
and the fact that Teresa David Cameron
um rode back on the very light touch
regulation that was recommended by Lord
Justice Levinson and then Theresa May
and Matt Hancock as the then culture
secretary not known for his Integrity
actually lied to a
um a select committee at the House of
Commons about the fact that Lord Justice
Levinson didn't want this part two to go
ahead when in fact he did and that's the
level at which they're being held to
Ransom rather than account yeah sadly we
can't speak to them uh tonight but just
finally
um Jackie you know when when the phone
hacking Scandal first broke um the
public I think understandably and
rightfully were pretty disgusted by it
all these years later Harry sort of
needs public opinion on his side he
needs the public behind him doesn't he
if he wants to really change what goes
on in the British press has he got that
still do you think do you think you
still have that in your campaign well I
think you have to look at it through the
filter of the Tabloid press and the
people things have changed a lot though
haven't they well I I would dispute that
in as much as we don't have a regulator
which is independent until that stage
where the public can have faith that the
information they're being given is not
being filtered through an agenda by a
news by a news editor or by an owner of
a tabloid newspaper which is why what
and you see the information flow from
government to the public it's being
filtered through this skewed bias and
until we can trust what we read in our
newspapers this culture needs to be
challenged because nobody else is
challenging it and it is really
frightening today challenged tabloid
newspapers they are so powerful and
nobody is holding them to account uh
Jackie we're out of time but it's been
great seeing you this evening thank you
very much for coming in let's take a
look now at a little bit more of the
Duke's 50-page witness statement Harry
wasn't shy in naming those who he
believes are responsible for the alleged
intrusion against him namely the daily
mirrors former editor Piers Morgan this
is what his statement said again the
thought of Piers Morgan and his band of
journalists earwigging into my mother's
private and sensitive messages in the
same way as they have me and then having
given her a nightmare time three months
prior to her death in Paris makes me
feel physically sick and even more
determined to hold those responsible
including Mr Morgan accountable for
their vile and entirely unjustified
Behavior well this was Piers Morgan's
reaction a little bit earlier this
evening
you see it I'm sorry
I'm sorry it was vile and unjustified
what do you think
didn't see it
but I wish him luck with his privacy
campaign look forward to reading in his
next book
foreign
Morgan uh speaking a little bit earlier
Paul I'm sure you've got some reaction
to both what Pierre said and what Jackie
had to say
yes
um as far as Peter I mean we said last
night that peters's name was going to
actually come up again and again and
again today as it as indeed it did
um
and
I've rarely seen peers so um on medicine
should we say honestly not not saying
very much but I suspect apparently he
hasn't been mentioned uh today's events
on his program tonight on a rival
Channel which I suspect is probably on
legal advice peers of course strongly
denies that he have a hacked a phone or
authorized hacking a phone
um but undeniably
a lot of settlements were made for you
know have been made by the mirror group
During the period when he he was edited
not all of them because he left and and
others took over but but but certainly a
significant amount of those large
payouts by the mirror group took place
during during his tenure which which of
course Harry's legal team will be
arguing well
an editor should know if you don't know
you know you ought to know so he of
course denies all knowledge doesn't he
of knowing about these uh these various
practices
um we're going to leave it there for the
moment uh we'll chat again uh shortly I
just want to tell you about the legal
team for the news paper group that's
been quizzing Harry on whether
journalistic Endeavor rather than
illegal means could have been the source
for stories the lawyer cross-examining
the prince referred to this article here
it is Beach Bum Harry from 2003 it's
when the prince was on holiday with
friends in Australia he said a piece by
the evening standard had come out days
before the article in the mirror and he
put it to Harry that anyone who wanted
pictures of him he was staying in the
resort of Noosa in Australia just had to
head there surely
though I would argue is a bit of a
needle in a haystack Andrew Green
responded with the notion that many
photographers were prepared to look for
that needle in the haystack yes again am
I right in saying the article is written
by Jane Kerr well there the Duke is
referring to the journalist Jane Kerr
and Andrew Green struggles to find if
she is indeed the author he rifles
through his papers and while he's doing
that Prince Harry jumps in so I think it
would be much better to ask her than me
she'd be more in the know I believe
the lawyer then says well I'm here to
cross-examine you I'm afraid that's the
way this works Prince Harry I understand
that
Mr Green then asks Prince Harry if he
recalled the efforts of a local
journalist to track him down during his
time on the Sunshine Coast
yes and deeply disturbing that looking
for me was regarded as a hunt my Lord
could I add that again based on my own
experience and knowledge in a lot of
these articles and many since a lot of
false information was put in these
articles to throw people like myself off
the scent I somewhat reject an article
by a Paparazzi or photo agency as proof
of the story because if I was that
person I would make up that story some
different story to how that hunt
happened as opposed to reality of it to
to cover up the true unlawful means of
that hunt
based purely on my experience my life
and and what I read about my life
stories have been clouded shrouded and
concealed in lots of false information
which is why I wasn't aware I had a
claim for so long
always being a bit naive
um in not quite understanding the
lengths and efforts that tabloid hacks
will go to to get that front page
picture of him on the beach or whatever
it might be yes I do I I mean whether
you like them or not Paparazzi are very
resourceful and they know you know the
likely places a celebrity or the royal
family might go for a quiet time so so
they could actually just be determined
to look everywhere also also Harry can't
rule out
that somebody who spotted him even
though it's a pretty remote area it's
not that remote that uh you know that
somebody might have spotted him there
and actually you know an old-fashioned
tip-off in fact you know as we all know
some of the tabloids you know but it's
not illegal put out you know if you've
got a story ring you know the news desk
on him
I suppose it all it's all a part of this
dance isn't it Persephone between the
press and the royal family that they
they use the press and they need the
media when they want them but when they
don't things can can go wrong for them
and of course we saw it most famously
with Diana yeah it's a delicate balance
and it was brought up actually in the
evidence today when Harry said you know
of course we did we did provide for
example on holidays we did provide
photographs and interviews to the Press
at the start of the trip in the hope
that then they would you know leave us
alone for the rest of it and there was
some quite immersive points he made on
on that today there was also talking
about the points he made just then
there's quite a lot of eye rolling in
the the journalism room as those sorts
of points were being made actually
during the evidence I mean you've got a
book out which it looks at exactly this
point doesn't it that relationship
between the media and the royalty yeah
it's called it's called reporting
royalty in fact you know and the time is
interesting because it looks at both the
past the present and throwing forward
the future of the the relationship
between the media the monarchy which
which they both need each other but
interesting interestingly it includes
looking at Harry's case but
if and it's a big if but if Harry were
to have a resounding victory in this
case I said if then then it could have
huge implications for both the royal
family and the media and public trust
and in a way it could be it could be
make leberson look like a vicarage tea
party if it went that way I'm not saying
it will we don't we don't know which way
it's going to go yet but we've just got
a few seconds left uh Persephone you're
in court today just sum up your thoughts
in 20 seconds or so uh forensic
questioning by um the mirror groups
Barrister and um I'm I think he's going
to put it all together tomorrow to try
to seek to make this point that actually
it's not these 33 articles which are the
problem it's the bigger picture yeah and
we will hear more from Prince Harry
tomorrow Persephone Paul thank you both
very much indeed it's been great to get
your analysis and your thoughts this
evening well there we have it Prince
Harry has given evidence in the witness
box at the high court in his case about
allegations of unlawful information
gathering against the mirror group
newspapers now we weren't able to play
what happened in court firsthand so this
was our way of showing you with the help
of our actor thank you very much to our
guests uh tonight Paul con you former
editor of the Sunday Mirror former
deputy editor The Daily Mirror and the
media commentator Persephone Bridgeman
Baker media lawyer and partner at Carter
Ruck thank you to our guests and for you
for watching but that's not it tomorrow
we'll have more from the Royal courts of
Justice when the Duke of Sussex takes to
the stand once again good night
this is Prince Harry arriving at the
high court
he wants to be here he wants this moment
in court
these articles were incredibly invasive
deeply disturbing that looking for me
was regarded as a hunt